[Applause]  pardon foul by Ingram do they count it  nope they say the foul occurred before  the gather and he never put the ball  back down and I think another technical  fouls been handed out now Abram looks  like he's confronting Jason Phillips on  a technical foul was on Ingram - shovin  James Harden after that play not sure  why what happened Ingram was usually  putting mild-mannered it's hot now Paul  punches are thrown Paul entrando  throwing punches  Antron comes in he's throwing punches  security trying to separate so some of  the teammates or that quickly erupted  into something ugly Lee getting Paul out  of it as Mark said when Chris Paul was  over here he said that Rondo spit on him  [Applause]